[Music]
on this sunday night
banning travel between provinces ybc
is considering it is there good evidence
that
a lot of transmission is coming from
interprovincial travel
the red flags from the legal community
alberta
eases pandemic restrictions but is it
too soon
if we instead start to undermine that
success we'll be right back to where we
were
cases are still high and the health care
system is strained
plus russia's opposition leader is
detained upon landing in moscow and the
world condemns the murders of two female
judges
in afghanistan
global national with robin gill
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us federal and provincial leaders have
urged canadians to avoid non-essential
travel
internationally and domestically to
contain covet 19
with the exception of atlantic canada
and the territories
most of canada has not been subject to
inter-provincial travel restrictions
but this week british columbia's premier
raised the possibility
john horgan is consulting with experts
to determine
if it's worth imposing limits on people
coming from other provinces
and if it's even legal julia foy has our
top story tonight
the combination of deep powder and low
covid numbers
is attracting visitors to north
america's biggest ski resort
from outside bc
bc's premier is concerned about the
threat of covid spreading from travelers
and is exploring the idea
of shutting the door i want to put this
either to rest so that british
columbians understand that we cannot do
that
and we're not going to do that or there
is a way to do it and we're going to
work with other provinces to achieve it
the atlantic provinces were the first to
develop a bubble to restrict
outside visitors but experts warn it's
not a one-size-fits-all solution
it's very different from atlantic
provinces sometimes it is almost
impossible to
truly patrol travelers coming through
the mountains and through various parts
of british columbia
in addition to geographical challenges
there are legal hurdles too
just by virtue of there being a pandemic
and a public health crisis doesn't mean
that we
that we toss the constitution out the
window zweibel contends that a
government has to prove
there's a problem first is there good
evidence that
a lot of transmission is coming from
inter-provincial travel and is there
also good evidence that there's
no less restrictive alternative that
would work
to to deal with that the provinces of
quebec
and manitoba have brought in
restrictions which require
all inter-provincial travelers to
quarantine for two weeks
even domestically try not to
undertake non-essential travel is
actually
important not just for the international
context at the moment
more draconian measures have been tried
around the world
australia locked down the state of
victoria for 111 days
while south korea gained access to the
public's private information
to track their travel movement professor
mendes thinks
there's a better way if let's say the
the ski slopes could be the cause of
major the super spread
then think about specific messages
attached to them
using the evidence of what devastation
could be caused
julia foy global news vancouver
new brunswick has restrictions on
travelers entering from other provinces
but it's now dealing with the highest
case numbers since the start of the
pandemic
there were 36 new infections confirmed
in the past 24 hours
the most in a single day bringing the
number of active cases
to nearly 300. most of the new cases are
in the edmondson region
which will now move into the province's
red alert level of restrictions at
midnight
the premier warns the fredericton
moncton and st john regions
could soon follow suit we need to buy
time
for the vaccine to be rolled out we must
all take this seriously
because the next step after the red
alert
is an entire lockdown we have seen that
in our neighbors in quebec in ontario
and further west much of canada has
tough covet 19 restrictions
but alberta has started to ease its
measures on monday
outdoor gatherings will again be
permitted and hair salons can once again
take appointments
the provincial government says it's
being cautious by reopening the economy
slowly but as heather york's west
explains alberta's health care system
is still under a lot of strain february
20th
9 a.m for hair stylist beth lloyd the
past
month has been stressful it's definitely
been challenging
i'm lucky because my kids are older and
they have been in school
but i know a lot of other stylists are
just hustling like
doing skip the dishes driving a lot of
people's
businesses didn't even survive starting
monday alberta stylists like
lloyd will be able to return to work
just a week after
opening schools to in-person learning
the province has decided to ease
restrictions once again
we can't entirely ease up on this goal
but
we can make small adjustments to provide
albertans with some
limited activities those activities
include appointment based personal care
services
and outdoor gatherings of up to 10.
funerals can now include as many as 20
people as well
after peaking in early december
alberta's daily infection numbers have
come down
we've had some very good numbers over
the holidays and and i think
many of us are surprised that we haven't
seen a christmas surge which is
you know fantastic news but the province
is still seeing nearly a thousand new
infections of covet 19 each day
and hospitals are still under strain
it's why a committee of edmonton doctors
chaired by alberta's former chief
medical health officer
is calling on the province to wait
before opening the economy anymore
you should wait four weeks and then not
activate the next phase unless you're
sure that the previous one
worked if alberta doesn't build on the
success that we've had
if we instead start to undermine that
success
we'll be right back to where we were
particularly with the added risk of two
highly transmissible variants of the
virus the road to a safe reopening
has become more perilous than before
heather urex west global news
calgary the u.s military remains on high
alert tonight in washington
ahead of wednesday's inauguration of
president-elect joe biden
within hours of being sworn in biden
intends to reverse some of donald
trump's most controversial policies
jennifer johnson has more on the
democrats plan for his first day
in office the inauguration stage at the
u.s capitol is quiet
a dress rehearsal ahead of wednesday's
ceremony was canceled due to security
concerns
trump defense officials say they will
protect washington no matter what
the commander in chief says or does we
take
homeland security very very
seriously we deal with a lot of
curveballs
of all kinds and yet we march forward to
keep the american people as safe as we
possibly can
lawmakers are shocked at what washington
looks like now
it reminds me of visiting baghdad going
to the green zone and seeing
so much military presence and barricades
i never thought i would see that in her
own capital or that it would be
necessary but there is a profound threat
from domestic violence extremists
on wednesday morning president-elect joe
biden will not be greeted at the white
house by president donald trump
as his tradition good afternoon folks
biden is already laying out his first
100 days in office
facing an economic crisis heightened
race relations
and a pandemic that has claimed 400 000
american lives
he has just named a new team of
scientific advisors
we're going to lead with science and
truth we believe in both
this is how we're going to god willing
overcome the pandemic and build our
country back
the day he takes office biden will undo
several trump policies
the u.s will rejoin the paris climate
agreement and repeal the ban preventing
citizens from coming into the u.s
from certain muslim countries biden will
also sign an order protecting people
from evictions
and require masks on federal property
and for interstate travel
president-elect biden then president
biden is going to come into office and
take decisive steps
to roll back some of the most egregious
moves of the trump
administration biden has spoken to
lawmakers in congress
asking them to push his agenda forward
including new economic
and immigration reform packages while
also holding president trump's
impeachment trial in the senate
a challenging start for a new president
trying to heal a country
after four turbulent years jennifer
johnson global news
washington state capitals across the u.s
are preparing for any insurgents ahead
of biden's inauguration
today there were calls for trump
supporters to protest the results of the
american election
but for the most part it was quiet even
so
there are still concerns the smallest
spark will ignite a fire of protests
tonight mike armstrong reports from
pennsylvania
it was a very visible show of force
police officers and national guard
stationed on every side of the
pennsylvania capitol complex
as it turned out few protesters turned
up
my free speech has been shut down there
was one local man
arguing the election was stolen from
donald trump and just meters away
three anti-trump protesters i feel safe
yeah i was wondering in the way down how
safe this would be
most state capitals were quiet for days
authorities have been saying protesters
would be
out that may have kept people away we
come in peace
in lansing the capital of michigan there
was a small protest
organizers say it had been planned for
weeks the siege on the u.s capitol
january 6
they say wasn't the reason they were out
it's the reason they considered
canceling
the 6 changed everything for us it made
us really worried about coming out here
obviously you see the fences
they were really worried the fbi stopped
by my work three days ago to talk to me
about coming out here now the fbi had
warned
all 50 states that extremist groups
could be planning protests
as a result in some states people who
applied for protest permits were denied
that may be one reason so few showed up
another
may be all the arrests since the capital
riot the fbi picked up another suspect
in nashville tennessee sunday morning
but it's been 10 days of arrests and
perp walks it likely isn't inspiring
more towards protest or insurrection
it may be dissuading them whatever it is
the mayor of washington says the threat
of domestic terrorism
has to be taken more seriously we never
believed
that so-called patriots would attempt to
overthrow their government
and kill police officers but that's
exactly what happened
the extra security won't stop today most
states will continue to protect their
capitals
through wednesday's inauguration robin
mike armstrong
in harrisburg pennsylvania the occupant
of the white house can make a big
difference for canada
the transition from donald trump to joe
biden could impact
everything from trade to the way
canadian politicians
talk about each other here's david aiken
with nearly two billion dollars worth of
goods crossing the border every day
the canada u.s trading relationship is
each country's biggest
and most important under donald trump
though that relationship took some hits
now with trump set to leave office next
week there is hope his successor
democrat joe biden will be easier to
deal with
there is no doubt that open and fair
trade with canada is good for americans
and you know the democrats know that
they might but there will still be
challenges for example
while trump gave the green light to the
keystone pipeline
biden has vowed to cancel that project
and from canada's viewpoint
democrats are as bad as republicans when
it comes to imposing
harmful duties on canadian softwood
lumber
the final days of the trump presidency
have also had an impact on canadian
politics
the dc riots had many canadians thinking
about the conduct
of their own politicians the liberals
have
ramped up attacks on the conservatives
accusing them of using trump-like
language
join our fight let's take back canada
when they make comments that are
inappropriate and that can be
interpreted in the wrong way
and if if it means calling them out i
think we
as canadians and as a society need to do
that if the liberals want to label me as
far right they are welcome to try
conservative leader aaron o'toole
said in a statement his office released
sunday canadians are smart and they will
see this as an attempt to mislead people
and import
some of the fear and division we have
witnessed in the united states
now that statement from o'toole is
unlikely to be the last word on the
matter
there is likely to be a federal election
in canada this year and already
the liberals are trying to paint
canadian conservatives
as bad and dangerous as those extreme
american republicans
and that too is another legacy of donald
trump
north of the border robin david aiken in
ottawa thanks david
the wreck of a fishing boat that went
missing off the coast of nova scotia in
december
has been found in the bay of fundy the
chief william solis was found
60 kilometers under water sitting
upright
because of the depth the vessel can't be
recovered recovery teams are now
assessing ways to reach it and search
inside
an emergency beacon on the scalloped
dragger was activated on the morning of
december 15th
the crew was on its way back to digby
after a week-long fishing trip
one body was recovered the evening the
boat capsized
but the bodies of five others are still
missing
coming up what was waiting for russia's
opposition leader
when he landed in moscow
the kremlin's most prominent critic has
been detained by police
upon returning to moscow russian
officials say alexi navalny was arrested
for probation violations
and will remain in custody pending a
court hearing the russian opposition
leader spent the previous five months in
germany
recovering from poisoning that he blames
on the kremlin
labs in several european countries
confirmed navalny was exposed to the
nerve agent novichok
the kremlin has repeatedly denied
poisoning navalny
in afghanistan an investigation is
underway into the murders of
two female judges local media say the
women worked for the supreme court
and were on their way to the office when
they were ambushed
no one has claimed responsibility for
the attack targeted killings of
government officials
journalists and activists have increased
in recent months
across the country still ahead survivors
of ireland's
mother and baby home say it's too late
to apologize
for thousands of children who died
ireland's prime minister and the head of
the catholic church in that country
have formally apologized for how
thousands of unmarried mothers and their
children were treated
the long-awaited report into the
so-called mother and baby homes
found evidence of rampant infant
mortality more than 9
000 children died at the church-run
institutions
as redmond shannon reports many
survivors say the report
and apology fall short
suspicions about what lay beneath this
patch of grass
triggered the report into another deeply
painful part of ireland's history
human remains found in a burial chamber
inside a decommissioned septic tank
most likely children born in one of
ireland's mother and baby homes
the secret of institutions run by the
catholic church were places for
unmarried mothers to give birth
something considered scandalous in
ireland up until the 1990s
were neglected no law showing whatsoever
it wouldn't have been done to animals
what was we had to suffer
and babies crying crying
through the night the report five years
in the making says
one in six children died in the homes
about
nine thousand in total but no one knows
for sure
records were often not kept i apologize
for the profound
generational rung visited upon irish
mothers
and their children who ended up in a
mother and baby home
or a county home the report says the
unmarried pregnant women were not
forced into the homes but in a society
gripped by catholic shame and guilt
they often had nowhere else to go one
hard truth
in all of this is that all of society
was complicit in it that assertion by
ireland's prime minister mihal martin
has angered survivors
they say the blame lies purely with
political leaders
and their one-time de facto partners the
catholic church
and you've seen here today that we're
all responsible i am not responsible
my family was not responsible the people
i know were not responsible
the report also says adoptions were not
forced
i did not abandon my child
the movie philomena based on a true
story paints a different picture
as do the stories of many survivors and
they say
the leaking of the report before they
saw it only continues the trauma
we expect as we always expected truth
justice
accountability resulting in prosecutions
shall they arise and restitution for
survivors
the government says it wants to change
ireland's complex privacy laws to allow
all survivors to find their biological
families
redmond shannon global news london
up next we catch up with the faces of
the front line who are helping us all
make sense of this pandemic
[Music]
comedian and tv legend betty white isn't
having a party despite celebrating her
99th birthday
the star of golden girls and five-time
emmy winner is loki this year
in an email to the associated press
white says her only plans
are feeding a pair of ducks then having
a hot dog with french fries
she adds since i'm turning 99 i can stay
up
as late as i want with over 80 years in
television white has the longest career
of any entertainer
in the industry experts in infectious
diseases have been helping the public
make sense of the virus
in a short period of time these doctors
have become household names
our jeff semple caught up with a few of
them to discuss their own experiences
during this pandemic
this is a rare moment
a chance for suman chakrabarty to stop
and catch his breath on a personal level
it's been a tough year and the past
couple of weeks have been some of the
toughest
so right now it's too much chakrabarty
is an infectious diseases physician
in mississauga just west of toronto in
one of the hardest hit regions in the
country
we have you know a thousand cobit cases
but when you actually see a person's
face and you see their story
you hear them you're able to comfort
them and answer their questions
and when it comes to answering
complicated questions it turns out
chakrabarti has a knack here to answer
our latest pandemic questions
infectious diseases specialist dr suman
chakrabarti
over the past year he's given countless
media interviews
helping to talk canadians through the
pandemic
i always like to give positive messaging
nobody likes you finger wagging i think
with that in mind
you can really be effective at messaging
and i try that every day and he's not
alone
a zoom call with some of chakrabarty's
closest
oldest friends whose names you might
also
recognize yes wow
you you like beat us all for backgrounds
yeah
that's an excellent background isaac
bogash zane chagla
and lisa barrett infectious diseases
physicians
who go way back they went to school and
trained together
quite frankly i think some of the best
friends i've made have been through
uh through training and just you spend a
lot of time together with people so you
get to know each other pretty well
and over the past year canadians have
also gotten to know them
these four friends have become
unexpected celebrities
providing a continuous carousel of media
interviews i got some very good advice
about five years ago from someone one of
my mentors who said
you know what if you're given the
opportunity to share information with
the public
do it do it often do it well because
otherwise someone else is going to fill
that void and you might not be as happy
with the message and in this pandemic
there's been no shortage of
misinformation
it's wild watching an idea
that's wrong or misinformed
form online what a task it is
to combat that jeff semple global news
mississauga ontario
and that is global national for this
sunday i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is montreal where
families built these friendly snow
people
outside care homes as part of a facebook
challenge to bring some snowy smiles to
seniors
who are staying inside in isolation
thank you for watching donna friesen
will be back here tomorrow
good night
[Music]